basically all it takes to silence a
majority is a very loud
very aggressive and intransigent
minority you can renormalize an entire
institution
by using by getting maybe 20 percent of
people inside an institution to be very
loud
and very solidified and uh and and
repeating the same thing over and over
and over which of
course is what the left is very good at
and you can see this happen in your own
life like
the example that's used by the same
nicholas talib is the example of
you you have a family of four and the
daughter decides one day she's
vegetarian so she comes home she says to
mom
i'm vegetarian and i want a vegetarian
meal and mom says okay well i can either
make two meals one that's vegetarian for
her and one that's
good for everybody else or i can make a
vegetarian meal for everyone
and so mom decides i'm making a
vegetarian meal for everyone well
daughter has now re-normalized the
family
the family is now vegetarian because
daughter was in transgender and you can
expand that outward right the whole
family now wants to go to a block party
they say to the person at the block
party we need a vegetarian meal for us
because of our daughter
and the person says okay do i really
want to you know go out and buy two
meals i'll buy one meal now everybody's
vegetarian because of this one person
you can see that sort of stuff happening
inside our institutions it requires
intransigence and it requires solidity
you can't move on the position you have
to be really intransigent
and the imposition that you're making on
somebody has to be just minor enough
that they don't really fight back
against you
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
the founding editor-in-chief of the
daily wire the host
of the ben shapiro show author of the
new book the authoritarian moment how
the left weaponized america's
institutions against
dissent and the fastest talking jew
on all of the internet ben shapiro
welcome back to the reuben report hey
good to talk to you
all right my friend first off i googled
that and it did you did come up as fast
as talking jew
on the internet how do you feel about
that i mean accurate
also i don't know it would be flatter or
insulted but you know it is what it is
life is reality facts don't care about
my feelings it's all right
facts do not care about your feelings
all right so look we're going to get
into the book obviously this is what
your 87th book or
95th or where are we at now yeah
something like that i i can never
remember it's either my 11th or 12th
depending on the case yeah
it's a lot of books as a guy who just
finished my second i admire someone that
has written this many books
um but let's just start sort of just
generally with what's going on in the
world which will kind of get us to the
book because that's really what this is
all about
uh kovid's a little bananas right now
now or at least the reaction
to kovid uh where are you at at this
point with the whole thing
so the pandemic is over as far as i am
concerned from a public policy
perspective that does not mean that the
pandemic is like technically over like
you can walk outside without vaccination
without mask everything's fine
but what it does mean is that all public
policy is designed to do is achieve
certain objectives originally
we were told that the public policy with
regard to covid was designed to prevent
the overrunning of the hospitals and so
we all locked down and we all messed up
and then we prevented the overrunning of
the hospitals and then the idea was okay
well now we're gonna delay indefinitely
until we can get to the vaccine
and then these miraculous vaccines came
around and the idea was okay the
vaccines are now available and then we
said okay well we'll wait until
every adult has had the chance to either
take it or not take it as the case may
be because they are super duper
effective
and now we've reached that and now the
problem is there's no actual next goal
and this is something that is driving me
up a wall if you listen to
people on cnn or msnbc or in the
administration talk
it seems that the goal is zero covet
like every single person in the united
states getting
getting the vaccine and then kovi just
going away and no one actually thinks
this is ever going to happen
this is a disease that has been seeded
over every country pretty much on planet
earth
it's taken a minimum of 4 million lives
probably closer to 6 million if you look
at the actual stats from india
and certainly if you include the actual
number of dead from china and a lot more
lives than that
and the the notion that this is just
going to go away if we yell at people to
get the vaccine is crazy which which
means to me that basically
now that every adult has had the
opportunity to take the vaccine and
because thank god this disease is not
really affecting kids in
in severe ways like the total number of
kids under the age of 18 who have died
is still under 350
in a subpopulation of 75 million we're
done
i mean as far as public what public
policy can accomplish or should seek to
accomplish
we are pretty much done at this point
and the problem for the left is that
they set
as a goal the idea of zero covered back
last year
and now they can't let go of it so biden
is kind of stuck between a rock and a
hard place on the one hand he wants to
clear covered over so we can all go back
to work and everybody can enjoy life and
he can say that he beat the thing
on the other hand he's actually in order
to do that he has to acknowledge
that we have to live with the virus
which would open the can of worms that
last year democrats said we should
certainly not live with the virus and
anybody who said we should live with the
virus like governor desantis in florida
was bad and evil so instead we're going
to get this ridiculous specter of people
trying to scare you
into being okay with giving up liberties
that really at this point there's no
scientific rationale for so you're going
to continue masking your kid
even though again this thing is not
radically damaging to children i mean
810
kids died of pneumonia in the same
period that coveted killed something
like 350 kids over the course of the
last year and a half or so
the the you're supposed to mask up your
kid to protect a 40-year-old who decided
not to get the vaccine or if you're
vaccinated you're supposed to mask up in
case god forbid you give it to somebody
who again
decided not to get the vaccine like that
none of that is good public policy so
i'm
i'm annoyed by it i'm frustrated by it i
also think it's a bad incentive
structure because i don't know why i
who according to peop the powers that be
did the right thing i got vaccinated my
wife got vaccinated my parents got
vaccinated
why am i supposed to penalize myself by
masking up to protect people who are
overtly not only not vaccinating but
also saying they don't care whether
i wear a mask or not it's bizarre what
would you say to those people at this
point because there obviously are a lot
of people i think it might be as many as
something like 30 to 40 percent of
american adults that are not vaccinated
that are saying i either had it and i
have the antibodies or i just don't want
this vaccine which basically was
produced in about a year or whatever
reasons that might have what would you
say to those people
at this point so number one you're a
free and independent human being you're
an adult and it's your decision that's
that's number one number two
if we're talking about you already had
covent i certainly see the rationale
there's some pretty good data suggesting
the natural immunity is
as strong if not stronger than vaccine
immunity what i would say is that for a
lot of people the
given evidence shows depending on your
age depending on your health factors
that your
rate of death from covid outweighs the
rate of adverse effects from the vaccine
so far as the data that we have yet seen
and this is
pretty much true for everybody above the
age of 18.
i haven't seen the data between 12 and
18 so much and certainly for kids
i have very little interest in
vaccinating my seven five and one year
old
at this point but if you're 35 years old
or 40 years old and you're saying well
you know
i i thought i got caught i'm hearing a
lot of this i thought i got coveted
but i wasn't actually tested for coco
but i'm sure i had it before well
unless you were tested for it it might
have been something else right there are
a lot of other sicknesses going around i
was sick several times during covenpic
never got covered so
don't rely on that take into account
your own risk factors and then
seriously consider getting the vaccine
because frankly the risks from the
vaccine from what i'm seeing in the data
are not particularly high and the risks
from covid
are depending on your age maybe somewhat
higher maybe multiple times higher
um but again i respect your abilities in
individuals choose as long as you're
willing to live with the consequences if
you don't get the vaccine and then you
get sick
you know that would be a you problem
don't don't come to public policy
seeking a solution
right to that point though how have you
in the last year have you figured out
who you can trust or what institutions
you can trust because it seems to me
we've just seen a complete
collapse across the board political
cultural
uh you know journalistic just the entire
thing has completely collapsed and
that's what people ask me
almost more than anything else at this
point dave who do you trust how do you
figure out how to make some sense of
this
i mean the way that i determine who to
trust is whether people were skeptical
of the official narrative
um but we're basing that in data so for
example one of the people who i
personally trust again named dr marty
mccarry from johns hopkins university
very early on he and i talked pretty
much every week on the show
and very early on he was very skeptical
of the lockdowns uh he was very
skeptical of the idea that if you're 20
years old you shouldn't be working or
that we should be
not treating people who are 20 uh in a
different way then we're treating people
who are 70 for example
because he was skeptical of that but he
was taking the science pretty seriously
uh i had a lot of respect for that same
thing with j batacharia from stanford
if you just bought hookline and sinker
the actual official narrative throughout
and the idea and you never cited the
data if you ever at any point said
the science says then i have pretty much
a problem with you because science is a
process science is not a person or an
institution
and so there's sort of a group of people
who i think were skeptical of some of
the narratives
and and who would do a good job it
seemed we
decided to trust in politics they do a
good job sort of seal manning the other
argument and then say okay here's where
i think the flaws are and they'd give a
nuanced picture of the data as opposed
to people who are just like
you listen to me and if you don't listen
to me you're an idiot in which case i
think pretty much always you don't
listen to those people
right so this will kind of segue us to
the book but are you surprised in the
last year i remember like two or three
weeks into kovid
it was one of the many times in the past
year that ben shapiro has trended on
twitter
because you said the very obvious
statement in essence that we are going
to have to live
with a certain amount of death a certain
amount is it's just what actuaries have
to deal with when they're figuring out
insurance rates
and that's just the reality of life and
of course everyone in media matters and
all the usual clowns
we're saying that ben shapiro wants to
kill old people and everything else but
are you related to that are you
sort of surprised how quickly everyone
folded and even
now you can sense that there's a certain
amount of people in the media
that want lockdowns again they want more
government programs like they just
they're getting off on this they just
they just like it yeah uh no i mean i
think that that is very true i think
this has become almost a pagan worship
ceremony for a lot of people um because
again i'm not anti-masking under certain
circumstances i'm not anti-masking for
unvaccinated people who are with other
unvaccinated people who are vulnerable
to covid i mean i i was never
anti-fouch until he started pretty much
overtly lying to us in a wide variety of
cases
i've been pro-vaccine throughout this
entire pandemic so yeah i
find it shocking however the number of
people who are much more interested in
castigating people
who are using their own independent risk
assessment and coming to a different
conclusion
or analyzing the data in a different way
but looking at the data i'm i'm
you know shocked at the number of people
who have decided that they are more
interested in the partisan virtue
signaling than
even examining the data that's the part
that i find really shocking
and the eagerness with which people are
going back to well you're not masking
this is where it's going to go right
they're going to say the cdc will issue
some sort of guidance saying if you're
vaccinated you ought to mask up and i'm
going to say no i've already said no
i vaccinated i am not transmitting the
disease
the numbers of people who are
asymptomatically transmitting copied
well vaccinated is very low the number
of breakthrough infections is very very
low according to the new york times 160
million people vaccinated in the united
states there's been something like 6 000
breakthrough cases
i'm not masking up for that and most of
all it's one thing to make the case that
i should mask up
if somebody can get the disease through
no fault of their own but if you've had
the opportunity to get a vaccine and
then you didn't and then i give you
covet
that one is kind of on you that's really
not on me anymore but
there will be this move like if somebody
says that you need to mask up despite
being vaccinated and you say no then it
will be back to oh you're willing to
kill grandma
it's like no i was never willing to kill
grandma yeah but
it's become much more about the partisan
it's why you see people yelling at
people who are unvaccinated right
it's not because they actually want to
convince those people to vaccinate if
you want to convince somebody to
vaccinate you do what i said earlier
you treat them as an individual human
being you take a look at the risk
factors you try to analyze those on an
individual level and assuage the fears
if you want to create a sort of
polarized
you're a bad person i'm a good person
thing then when you say you're an idiot
and a [ __ ] if you don't vaccinate on my
timeline as i seek as i see fit
and no matter your prior health scenario
right
you'll be proud to know ben as a refugee
of los angeles that you know we have
this mask mandate in effect again and i
went to a restaurant this weekend
i went to home depot this weekend and i
went to a mall this weekend
and i did not wear a mask and guess what
an awful lot of people nodded at me
you know in support a lot of people were
not wearing masks and yes when i went
into bloomingdale's and they asked me to
put the mask on
i did because i'm not trying to you know
get somebody fired or get into a fight
with somebody
but i bring it up because enough people
are sort of like
okay it is time to move on and that's
just where we're at at the moment
yeah well again i moved to florida and i
will tell you this if they try this
whole
vaccinated need to mask up again
nobody's doing it and people weren't
doing it
originally here i i can't imagine that
people are going to do it here and again
yeah the governor sands has been very
big on everybody should get the vaccine
if you are if you are physically able to
get the vaccine
and there's not much more than that that
he can do and i'm i'm just
i'm do i gotta say just on a data level
i'm bewildered by this i was looking at
the seven day running average of death
from covid the average number of deaths
from covet according to the new york
times seven-day rolling average right
now
is 269. and when we're at the height of
the pandemic it was well over 3000
people a day who are dying so we brought
down
that factor by a factor of 10 and we are
now seeing fewer people die
every day in the united states from
covet then die on a normal day
from diabetes right and 269 269 i mean
are they giving us ages on that or other
health you know the comorbidity stuff
because that's
that's a very small number of course we
don't want people to die but it's a
small number well i mean again
if you're going to talk about public
health crises then you really do have to
talk about the number of people who are
dying and the number of people who are
being hospitalized
and the fact that the media will do
things like play with stats where
they'll say well you know we've had a
40 increase in the number of
hospitalized from three weeks ago and
it's like
yes but the number of hospitalized three
weeks ago was very very low
like a 40 increase means we are still
very very low so
this doesn't mean that we're making
light of any of this sort of stuff what
it does mean is that statistically
speaking the people who are getting
serious breakthrough infections have
significant underlying illnesses
very significant underlying illnesses
and the people who are mostly getting
hospitalized and
and the people who are who are dying
tend to be people who are unvaccinated
and that really resides in sort of the
middle section of the age range of the
population because dirty little secret
pretty much everybody who's over the age
of 65 in this country got the vaccine
yeah ben i'm not a math a magician like
you are but if there's one person who
had covet and then the next week there's
two what's the percent increase on that
yeah it's a 100 increase right my god
that's a huge
huge increase all right well all of this
leads us perfectly
to the authoritarian moment because it
does seem like
we are in it right now um are you sort
of having a pat yourself on the back
moment because i've been feeling that a
little bit lately like
we were in a group of people that were
screaming about
all of this about five years ago not to
say there weren't plenty of people doing
it before that
but like we were really on the internet
like front end of like guys this
horrible thing is here
and everyone kept saying no no it's just
on college campuses and now it has burst
forth for everyone to see yeah no
question i mean
you know i used to think as a religious
jew there's a whole take on prophecy
that
the prophecy is like god speaking
through you but i tend to think now that
prophecy is more along my monadian lines
just seeing very clearly what's
happening right now
i think the reason that orwell's 1984 is
prophetic is not because it was prophecy
it's because he was actually describing
a thing that was happening in the soviet
union at the time
and so when we look at things happening
elsewhere like wow how could he foresee
he wasn't for seeing anything he was
literally describing
and describing what's going on you know
five years ago
and then looking what's happening just
it was a smaller phenomenon then it's a
much larger phenomenon now
and i don't think any of us were
prophets i think that we just all saw
clearly what was happening
and the direction that people were
moving and the authoritarianism that i
talk about in the book is really not
the government top-down authoritarianism
that we've worried about in the past the
idea the government is going to tell you
what to do although that may be the
natural outgrowth
of a sort of attitudinal
authoritarianism that's taken over
what i'm talking about more is all of
the institutions of society the
non-governmental institutions of society
in large part becoming more and more
intolerant of dissent outlawing dissent
social ostracization
people losing their jobs people having
family members not speaking to them
anymore and and this is leading to
a complete breakdown in the possibility
of us even having
a republic together it's really really
dangerous stuff and everybody feels it
this is the part that's amazing
is that we're all being gassed by the
media that says that this stuff is not
important
or that you know it's just making the
country better but by polling data
every single subgroup in the united
states including mainstream liberals
with the with the exception of far left
radicals with the exception the far left
every single subgroup in the united
states says they are afraid to say what
they believe about politics publicly
that's insane okay that is a good
indicator of where we are and
and how far we have to go what do you
make of the
the last liberals at this point i mean
do you
consider them part of a new conservative
movement or
some sort of wide tent thing on the
right i mean that's what i would say i'm
not talking about obviously the crazy
lefties
but the last few the the sam harris is
the barry weisses whoever else is left
like what do you what do you make of
that crew at this point i mean so
frankly i think that the
the future of the country rests on them
because i think that the folks in the
middle are going to have to make a
decision there are a lot of sort of
mainstream establishment liberals who
have a decision to make the decision is
this
they can either move along with the
hardcore left with whom they agree on
policy a lot of the time
and they can get their left-wing utopia
at the expense of individual rights
comedy having a country or they can say
to the radical left look we may agree
with you on a lot of your policy
prescriptions but the way you're going
about this is going to break the country
and we need to have these discussions
with people on the right we need to
preserve individual rights and if it
takes us longer to get where we're going
or maybe
even if we don't get there at all the
higher principles are still worth
standing up for
i am unsure of which way the
establishment liberals are going to go
because you do see things like the
harper's letter with 150
you know liberal intellectuals saying
that they they are very much in favor of
individual rights it would have been
nice to see one trump supporter on that
list
it would also be nice to know really
whether mainstream establishment
liberals
are interested in opening the overton
window wider than themselves in other
words are they saying we don't like
cancel culture for us
or are saying we don't or are they
saying we don't like cancel culture even
for people with whom we disagree so
today on twitter
i put out sort of a challenge uh maybe
called the nice bucket challenge but
the the the basic challenge is if you
are
a person in politics can you name and
publicly say about somebody who voted
differently than you that they're a nice
person
can you say that because the answer for
a lot of folks on the left is no
the answer for a lot of and i'm
including mainstream liberals there
people who just
will not treat you as a human being
publicly they won't come out and say
publicly
i disagree with this person on nearly
everything they're a nice person and
you should read their stuff and consider
it you say that kind of crap all the
time i say that all the time
i literally refer people to left-wing
podcasts and say you should listen to
them and listen to me and then decide
who you agree with i've never heard of a
left-wing podcast that has suggested
anything remotely similar about my own
ben because you're a nazi right duh
right i mean that's always worked
yeah i hate to tell you that i think i
can give you the conclusion on your
hypothesis here which is that they're
not
they're not for the most part going to
move in the direction you want them to
move i don't think they'll necessarily
move towards the left anymore
but they'll stay in this sort of
irrelevant limbo phase
because i i've met and i you know i know
a lot of these people and they just
more than anything else more than saving
the country they just don't want to be
called conservatives because you guys
are very scary
you guys are very very scary it's a real
problem and it's it's why
i open the book by talking about january
6th because i think that
there's a trick that's being played
right now and it it's why the democrats
are trying to the january 6th commission
make a big deal out of january 6. listen
january 6th was a big deal but it was a
big deal because law enforcement failed
to stop a couple of hundred idiots from
running into the capitol building the
notion that it was a full-scale assault
on democracy that was going to end with
the overthrow of our democracy
the worst democratic situation since the
civil war
in the words wait a minute wait a minute
aoc said that we were an
hour away from uh armed insurrection or
we were an hour away from martial law is
what you yeah it's insane i mean it's
it's totally and utterly insane
the what i what i pose at the beginning
of the book is a basic question who well
let me give you two realities okay one
is we have january 6th it's an act of
evil by a bunch of idiots who are going
to be arrested go to jail
then we have an entire left wing that
labels the entire right-wing responsible
for january 6 starts suggesting overt
social controls with regard to
media with regard to free speech starts
de-platforming places like parlor using
neutral service providers like amazon
web services
starts openly moving to push social
media
to ban people like mainstream
conservative voices
starts talking to corporations about how
they're not allowed to give any more to
members of the republican party who
didn't vote the way they wanted them to
vote
on certification of the election without
actually overthrowing the election right
which one is more authoritarian a bunch
of idiots running into the capitol
building and then getting themselves
arrested
or every major institution in america
declaring january 6th such an
unbelievable crisis that they have to
maximize their power over your life
i mean it seems to me that there's a
wild imbalance in the amount of
institutional support
from one authoritarian ideal versus the
other right and speaking of twitter
and today i just saw like within the
last hour that the adl
is now working with paypal to basically
you know hunt down white supremacists
which will be basically anyone who's not
a lefty
and then it's like all right well now if
you can't be on paypal what can't you be
on tomorrow is it going to be chase bank
is it going to be
some other financial service and that
white supremacist thing will keep
getting wider and wider
yeah what the left has succeeded in
doing is instead of just utilizing the
government to violate the first
amendment
instead what they've done is they found
a way to pressure private companies into
doing it
and this is really really dangerous
stuff you're seeing this with facebook
as well obviously last week npr ran an
entire piece it's a government-funded
entity they ran an entire piece
trying to push facebook into suppressing
traffic from my website they admit in
the ps
we don't lie they say we don't we don't
we don't engage in conspiracy theorizing
we openly admit at the bottom of every
single story and say and brag about the
fact that we are openly conservative
like and they should suppress their
traffic anyway like they're not even
trying to hide it at this point and then
they say well it's not a first amendment
issue
if government entities or or if the
white house is pushing private actors to
violate your first amendment rights
because those private actors are not
government entities
okay well if the government is
essentially chartering an institution
and then restricting what the
institution can and cannot do with the
first amendment they have become a
government agent and it's becoming very
very dangerous
it is the real issue there that we
simply don't know because it's like the
whole machine doesn't work anymore and
everything is so full
filled with lies that when jenn saki
says that the administration is
flagging posts for that was her word for
facebook
it's like yeah that obviously to us
seems like some sort of government
coercion related to a private company if
we're to believe that
facebook is private but the bigger issue
is it's like how are we ever gonna
really find out what they're doing
because there is no honest actor
to to deal with it right like we're
gonna have another congressional hearing
to figure out what happened
that's exactly right and one of the
bigger problems here is that as we
have seen and this was the the really
kind of revelatory moment of what
happened with parlor
for for a while the line from the left
and many people on the right including
people like me on the libertarian right
was okay if you don't like how twitter
handles its business go build your own
twitter
so then parlor built it's on twitter and
then the neutral service providers came
along and they were like what if we just
deny you neutral service
and and so you can see how how we moved
away from
you know there's sort of a baseline of
neutral service providers then you can
build it on top of that and compete
within that structure too
you have to build entirely parallel
mechanisms that that cost
billions and billions of dollars with
you know 30 years of head start
from the left on all of this stuff and
the government standing in the
background pushing i mean
that that is extremely dangerous stuff
and again the predictable result of all
this is going to be fragmentation
because people aren't going to go along
with this and you're going you're seeing
it right now you're seeing states
cracking down on facebook right but
since when did florida have an interest
in facebook since when does texas have
an interest
when these places started basically
mimicking the line of the democratic
party
and states said okay well the federal
government is no longer going to protect
our citizens so i guess we're going to
have to do it the fragmentation is upon
us
unless people back away do you think the
fragmentation is good i mean i'm sort of
at the point where
look we have a federalist system for a
reason you move to florida for a reason
like
let the fragmentation occur let local
governments figure out what's good and
then i would say
perhaps we just need a complete
fragmentation of the economy too and
we'll just i mean you know i'm working
on locals like we'll just
build different things and it kind of
sucks because i know that your
your gut feeling is that we shouldn't go
that route but it's like
i don't see an alternative yeah i mean
it may be an eventuality so it's not
something i would prefer i've said this
over and over and over again i would
prefer
we all be able to eat whatever
restaurant we want without having to
worry about the politics of the owner
but if the left is going to militarize
all of the institutions there's not
going to be a choice
and listen on a personal level it's fine
with me because i'll make plenty of
money from it i have a huge platform and
if there's going to be a conservative
razor company
it'll probably be branded by us but at
the same time
is that good for the country is it good
that you can identify your neighbor
by what you know what razor they they
use in the morning like i don't think
any of that is good for the country
and i also have real doubt that you know
we talk about the the fragmentation the
federalist system
the left is making increasingly clear
that they are not going to abide by that
right this is why they're attempting to
federalize all the election procedures
because their idea is not
okay texas does what texas does and
california does what california does and
we share our country and we have some
baseline rules at the top it's that
texas should not be allowed to do what
texas does and florida should not be
allowed to do it florida doesn't if you
don't like it well we're just going to
change the
law at the top line it's going to lead
to some pretty significant conflict
and and that's when things really start
to get dangerous as the left
continues to suck more power up into the
top level and then
cram down the california view on texas
or florida
yeah so listen i want to go through
quickly each a little bit on each
chapter but i want to jump to chapter
seven for a second
uh about fake news because you mentioned
the election stuff and and one of the
things i've been doing on the show in
the last
two three weeks is i've been reading
what's in these election bills what was
in hb3 in
in texas what they're doing in georgia
and there's nothing racist
in many cases it allows for more time to
vote and people
to actually you know for paper trails
and let's actually make sure there's
cameras when we're counting i mean
everything in these bills as far as i
can see it
is to make sure there is more
transparency but
the reason i liken this to chapter 7 the
fake news
is that the media will not cover these
things honestly the media keeps telling
us these bills are racist
they're about keeping black and brown
people from voting and no matter how
many times we expose them
jake tapper is not going to talk about
that brian stelter is not going to talk
about it new york times is not going to
talk about it
so what do we do i mean the the only
answer there is that
people in the states seem to know this
which is why they keep electing
republicans
i mean like these election security
bills are very popular in in the states
that they are currently being passed and
you're right i mean the media are
are at this point just open agents of
the democratic party pushing the
democratic party line whether it's
all misinformation ought to be banned
online or whether it's all these voter
fraud
all these voter fraud bills are really
about suppressing the black vote
let me put it this way the amount of of
the the lie
they keep saying it's the big lie that
voter fraud decided the last election
all right if that's a big lie it is just
as big a lie
voter suppression is widespread in the
united states that is just an overt
ridiculous lie
there is no evidence to suggest that
black people are being suppressed
on a systematic level and prevented
being from voting it's just not true
there is no evidence of it whatsoever
and yet that's the basis
of before the people act so the
democrats are like well you know you're
lying the lies about january 6th and
november 4th those are leading to all
these voter fraud bills okay even if
that were true the lies that you guys
are telling about voter suppression have
led to you trying to federalize the
entire system in violation of the
constitution
you're right the media lie about this
stuff on a routine basis and then they
obscure it by pretending that they're
objective
but i i think that their day of
dominance is ending which is why
i think that the discussion over the
fake news is actually secondary to the
discussion over social media because
what's happened
is that it used to be that you used to
bookmark all the sites that you wanted
to visit
and this is the old way of doing things
in 2003 2004 right you bookmark grudge
and then you bookmark
you know the huffington post and you but
you'd actually check all the different
sites individually
because everybody started getting their
news through these feeds whether it's
facebook or twitter
the centralization of news consumption
one source has allowed the left
to swoop in and then try to bottleneck
the amount of information that can get
out via these sources that's the part
that's really dangerous i'm not worried
about the new york times being a
propaganda
they've been a propaganda outfit as long
as i've been alive i'm much more worried
about them
trying to re-establish a monopolistic
control
of the dissemination of information than
i am about them being who they are
yeah so to that point can you talk a
little bit about your position
the difference between say a purely
libertarian position on big tech versus
a conservative opinion because this is
this is now becoming the hot thing it's
like maybe there's no chance maybe the
ship has sailed and we can't do anything
at this point
i'm guessing you don't want or at least
i've never heard you say that you want
you know government regulators with hard
hats you know walking into google to
look at the algorithm
but but what do you think we should or
could do
if anything so i think that the pretty
easy solution here
seems to be to make a minor change to
section 230
and the minor change would be to just
get rid of the catch-all clause so if
you take a look at section 230
section 230 says that we that you are
relieved from liability
as if you remove for example obscenity
or pornography or violent material
or anything otherwise objectionable is
that anything otherwise objectionable
that is the the catch-all provision and
i understand
why this originally was right to
understand why section 230 is drawn the
way it is you have to understand the
history a little bit basically
platforms were created these platforms
were open platforms and then
there was and and you didn't have
liability for what was on the platform
so long as you didn't police what was on
the platform because it was just like a
phone line
right would i say on the phone line if i
threaten to murder somebody 18c is not
responsible for that i'm responsible for
that okay so platforms we're basically
just you post something
the platform is not responsible for the
thing that you post then there was a
website that started going in and
deleting all the obscene material
and the people who are putting up the
material they said
you've now violated you you're now a
publisher
because you because you're editing and
you're deleting stuff this makes you a
publisher so if somebody posts something
defamatory and you don't delete it
you're a publisher you ought to be
treated with liability and so congress
said well that seems weird that if i
decide to get rid of obscenity it's now
my job
to treat my the entire platform as a
publisher well the problem is that has
now been completely reversed the idea
behind 230 was to
promulgate and allow people to get rid
of truly objectionable material
while not absorbing the liability of
becoming like the daily wire or the new
york times having to fact check every
post
because it's an open platform instead
what the left did is they reverse the
polarity they said well actually the job
now of section 230
is to make you into a publisher right
now your job is to remove
all of the objectionable constants
including politically objectionable
content
and we will threaten you with getting
rid of all section 230
protections if you don't get rid of
quote unquote misinformation well the
easy way to fix this
is to just get rid of the otherwise
objectionable clause meaning that
you can get rid of stuff that violates
the law you can get rid of stuff that is
pornographic
you can get rid of you know repeated
spam for example but
if you start discriminating on the basis
of politics you're no longer a
publisher you're no longer a platform
now you're a publisher and liability
attaches
but do you think we have a government or
any officials i mean there's a couple
republicans talking about this
you know mike lee and jim jordan rand
paul i mean a few people
but it's like do you think we have any
political will to actually ever do
anything other than have hearings about
this stuff like you think they can do
something well the problem is that
everybody says they want to do something
but the stuff they want to do is
radically different so democrats are not
in favor of getting rid of the
otherwise objectionable clause because
that would do what we're talking about
it would open up the platforms
instead what they would like to do is
close off the platform so what they
would like to do is treat facebook as a
monopoly
and then have somebody sit on top of the
government like an elizabeth warren
appointee
and decide what facebook can and cannot
put up and that of course is incredibly
dangerous
so you'll see these these new york times
articles where it's like oh there's
broad spectrum agreement that facebook
has to be regulated
well i mean that's that's really not
correct i mean
the question is what is the content of
the regulation it's it's like saying
that my child and i
have an agreement that there ought to be
consequences for not doing her homework
yeah my child's consequence is that
she would like to be able to eat cookies
and my consequences she goes to a room
like we agree there should there be
consequences but these are wildly
variant
yeah all right so let's let's just jump
into each chapter for a little bit
we've sort of bounced around through
some of them already how to
silence a majority is chapter one and it
does feel like
uh most people have been silenced just
by their own
acquiescence to all of this yeah that's
right
basically all it takes to silence a
majority is a very loud
very aggressive and intransigent
minority you can re-normalize an entire
institution
by using by getting maybe 20 percent of
people inside an institution to be very
loud
and very solidified and uh and and
repeating the same thing over and over
and over which of course is what the
left is very good at
and you can see this happen in your own
life like the example that's used by
nicholas talib
is the example of you you have a family
of four and the daughter decides one day
she's vegetarian so she comes home she
says to mom
i'm vegetarian and i want a vegetarian
meal and mom says okay well i can either
make two meals one that's vegetarian for
her and one that's
good for everybody else or i can make a
vegetarian meal for everyone
and so mom decides i'm making a
vegetarian meal for everyone well
daughter has now re-normalized the
family
the family is now vegetarian because
daughter wasn't transgender and you can
expand that outward right the whole
family now wants to go to a block party
they say to the person at the block
party we need a vegetarian meal for us
because of our daughter
and the person says okay do i really
want to you know go out and buy two
meals i'll buy one meal now everybody's
vegetarian because of this one person
you can see that sort of stuff happening
inside our institutions it requires
intransigence and it requires solidity
you can't move on the position you have
to be really intransigent
and the imposition that you're making on
somebody has to be just minor enough
that they don't really fight back
against you
right it can't be something where you
like demand that you're going to be the
you are the captain like you run the
place now
it can't be that it has to be something
where you know we just want diversity
training
that's all we want we just want
diversity training and if we get
diversity training then we'll be happy
and we'll leave you alone and we'll go
make our hr reports we won't file
lawsuits and everything will be good
and people in the middle like well you
know it's annoying but do i really want
to spend my day doing this
and and soon it escalates from okay we
need to we need just we need this this
anti-discrimination tree
uh we need diversity training too we
need active anti-racism training
and now you've got debra max kennedy in
there and they figure okay well ten
thousand bucks we can get these people
off our back abram x kennedy comes in
spouts and bull crap and
we all move on with our lives and they
say well yeah but here's the thing you
haven't established the principles of
equity we need hiring
based on race and now you start saying
okay well i don't really
like that but i'm also afraid that if i
fight back against you you might file
some sort of lawsuit and claim that i'm
discriminating against you and you might
lead a walkout so i guess we'll go along
with that
maybe and then it's everybody at the
company needs to put out a black square
right you can see how it just moves
along
because the more you give the more
you're willing to give does that also
tell you a little something about
the human condition because as you were
talking about that i mean you could have
given the exact same examples with covet
it was two weeks to flatten the curve it
was you know a month of lockdown now
it's a year and a half later let's mask
vaccinated people i mean it's just
something about humans and how much we
just
give in the face of tyranny right i mean
one of the great lies about human beings
that we're very confrontational we are
not we are very conflict diverse
and people who are who are conflict
seeking tend to be
the the winners in this particular game
theory situation right
it's like the kid in high school who's
the craziest kid no one wanted to fight
and maybe you could beat him in a fight
but you never knew whether he's gonna
pull a knife
and that that's these people working
inside companies it's like are they
gonna pull a knife are they gonna knife
you are they gonna knife your friends
are they gonna go after the heads of the
company are they gonna tank the stock
are they gonna lead to the new york
times
and maybe we ought to just give them
this little concession yeah it's it's
nuts
uh all right chapter two how the
authoritarian left re-normalized america
i mean we're watching
everything being sort of attacked right
now yeah i think that the key to
understand how this went from sort of
small institutions to the nation broadly
i think the obama presidency was
transformational
and i think the reason the obama
presidency was transformational is when
barack obama ran in 2008
he ran on the basis that he was going to
be a unifying force in america he's
going to bring together black and white
there was no black no white there were
just americans no red no blue right the
whole stick
and then after 2008 he governed very
very
much the left and there was the tea
party movement that cropped up there was
this really hard pushback against
obamacare in 2010 he takes according to
his own light to shellacking
and by 2012 he's no longer running his
unifier
he's decided you know what i can unify a
couple of different strands in leftist
thought
one strand is the very heavy
government-run progressivism that begins
in the early 20th century and i can i
can do that right that's my policy
and then the other strand is this this
kind of critical
race theory far left burn it all down
idea and these two ideas have been in
conflict right the radical left had
always said burn it all down we don't
trust lbj he's part of the system
burn it all down and then you had sort
of the moderate left which was let's
spend a crapload of money we can fix all
problems with the government now those
two things appear to be
sort of in conflict with one another but
barack obama brought them together
because what he said is yes i can do
anything with government right
and but i'm i'm actually tearing down
the system from the inside
right i took over the system i'm one of
you and i'm going to tear it down from
the inside on behalf of all of these
intersectional oppressed minorities
and we're going to cobble together a
coalition of the ascendant
and they're going to overwhelm the old
majority in the united states and we're
going to win for the rest of time and in
2012 when obama did that right he
overtly pandered to a wide variety of
intersectional groups he did he did
he did daca in order to appeal to
hispanics and then he did gay marriage
you remember in 2012 right in 2011 2012
right before the election that he makes
the shifts on gay marriage in order to
appeal
to the lgbt coalition and then he starts
making you know overt plays for example
with regard
to i believe made some overplays with
regard to asian americans
on certain issues and it was it was he
he was one of the first candidates to
have like specific
outreach groups for every intersectional
coalition member
and then the idea was and then we'll all
side together in the same way you see
this on college campuses
to fight the institutions and the powers
that be now the irony was
he was the institution he was the powers
that be but this is why he kept saying
right
we need to gut the institutions and
remake them right we need to remake them
from within you're getting the same
thing from biden now
right we have to build back better it's
not enough for us to go back to the
thriving economy that we had a couple
you know a year and a half ago no we
have to build back better we are going
to fundamentally re-change the
institutions
by combining the progressive power of
the government with
this revolutionary idea that the
institutions themselves are bad and need
to be uprooted
right and then we hear like my governor
at least for now
gavin newsom saying this is the
opportunity we've been looking for so in
some ways it's like yeah they did all
want this because now
federal bailouts suddenly california has
money even though money
isn't isn't worth much inflation that's
not a thing anymore right
yeah i mean the the basic idea from the
left has always been that emergency is a
ratchet it's a one-way ratchet and
whether you're talking about the great
depression or world war ii or whether
you're talking about
the so-called war on poverty and
certainly now every crisis is an
opportunity to grow government
and because the left thinks not only in
terms of institutional control but in
terms of doing things right the way that
you measure a good president according
to the left
is the president did things now the way
you measure a good president according
to the right is
did they pursue policies that were
effective in helping americans for the
left it doesn't matter
right the most transformative presidents
are the ones who may have lengthened the
great depression by
eight years and in turn hundreds of
thousands of japanese people but they
did a lot of stuff
and the same thing with lbj right he was
a terrible president he presided over to
the disastrous vietnam war
he presided over tremendous breakdown in
race relations he
did a couple of things that were
obviously very good the voter right with
the voting rights bill and the
and the civil rights act but overall not
a good president but a transformational
president because he did a lot of stuff
barack obama
much less successful president than bill
clinton bill clinton footnote to history
because he was too moderate
barack obama hugely important because he
passed obamacare and you're seeing the
same thing with biden now this is
biden's mentality with regard to
government action
so i've been thinking something that i'm
going to drop in this interview with ben
shapiro right now since you're bringing
up biden and obama
my suspicion and ben you know i'm going
off the grid in a week
but that the biden mental collapse is so
obvious
at this point that it can't hold much
longer and i think they thought they
were going to get at least a year i'm
not so sure they are
that the way it's going to break the
seal the way it's going to actually get
into mainstream because we can all talk
about it but no one will talk about it
on cnn
etc is that obama in an interview is
going to say something he's going to
have a one-liner saying you know maybe
joe's lost a step or two and then
suddenly everyone's going to start
saying it
what do you think about that i think the
only way that obama does that is if he
thinks that
there's a backup plan the problem for
the democrats no meaning he'll have a
full
backup plan but he'll be the one that is
basically going to take out biden i mean
i think that if that i think
if that does happen if there's a backup
plan you're right that it would be
obama who would do it he's the only
person inside the democratic party who
is well respected enough to get away
with it
the problem for the democrats is they
really really need joe biden i mean they
really need a job in because what's
waiting in the wings is kamala harris
and man is she unpopular and man is she
bad at this she is just garbage at this
job
and her job is really easy and she's
really terrible at it so
you know i i wouldn't honestly if the
democrats had a way of supplanting
kamala harris with michelle obama i i
think that they would try something like
that
yeah i'm just i just have a feeling it's
gonna be obama that's the one that's the
airlock basically because he's the he's
the one that will just slightly leak it
out and then the plan will be there that
is my
almost august prediction all right
chapter three you sort of hit on some of
this already
the creation of a new ruling class that
that seems to be what this is all about
right now
yeah well i think this is really about
the university system so there was this
sort of presumption
uh by people on the right that what
happens in the university stays in the
universities and that's not correct
basically
an entire ruling elite class was created
in the universities
to understand why that is you have to
understand what universities have become
it used to be
universities trained you to be a good
citizen and also trained you for a job
and now unless you are what we call the
ucla south campus major right
a stem major they're not training you
for either they're training you to not
be a very good citizen
but they are training you to be a
membership of the ruling class and the
way we can tell you're a member of the
ruling class is you speak the lingo
right this is what colleges have become
there's a reason like what did you learn
in college
i was a north campus major not much i
came out with a credential what does the
credential mean the credential means two
things one
i'm smart enough to make through college
and two i've now been trained in
speaking the language of the
sophisticates and this is what you see
on twitter when people put their
pronouns in their profiles for example
it's the reason why people put their
college degrees in the in their profiles
it's because it is saying i am a member
of the elect
now what they hate more than anything is
if you're a member of the elect but you
don't actually
speak the lingo or you don't like the
lingo that's not okay but
we've created this sort of super powered
group of people who are going to run the
world and we did it
by sending them to these institutions
where they
rack up massive amounts of debt and
learn what they are supposed to say at
cocktail parties in order that they are
well accepted
in the halls of liberal intelligentsia
and in the halls of power
and and that's that's a real problem
because the reality i mean as peter
thiel is fond of saying is that
you know college does not educate you
for a job there we'd be much better off
if we had an apprenticeship system in
the united states for most jobs
and college is is basically a place
where you go to get a credential and
blow a couple hundred thousand bucks and
drink
by by the time your kids uh who are all
under 10
by the time they make it to college age
do you think college is going to look
anything remotely like it looks i don't
know i mean i think by the time my kids
are in college
i think that everything is going to be
online i think they're going to be able
to pick and choose what kind of courses
they want to take
and i think frankly that a lot of
businesses will have gotten wise to the
scam that college is and they'll just
start hiring directly out of high school
i think you're going to see people going
back to almost an old model where they
say okay well you got straight a's in
high school you're obviously smart come
here an apprentice for
two three years and and then we'll pay
you
chapter four how science trademark
defeated actual science this was making
me think of that great
fouchy line when he basically said i am
the science he went full palpatine
on us that's basically what's happened
here right you challenge this guy and
you're challenging
science yeah and this is the schtick of
the left is that there are two problems
with regard to science and and
the sort of move toward authoritarianism
one is the idea that the science is an
institution
and not in in actual process right
normally science is a process not an
institution
when you have fouchy declaring order 66
uh on everybody who disagrees with them
uh it's it's obviously indicative of a
broader mindset the two big problems
with that you see
inside the scientific community are one
i label the ultra crepitarian problem
mainly because i love the word ultra
crepitarian but basically that's the
word speaking outside of your your
actual purview
so you see this from for example during
the last pandemic
uh when people said all of a sudden that
racial justice
was a health issue you said yourself
hold up a second how did you explain
that one how exactly is racial justice a
public health issue
and there's no actual rationale it's
just we're scientists we have a doctor
in front of our name
therefore respect me when i talk about
race relations so well you don't know
anything about race relations i don't
know what you're talking about right so
scientists speaking outside their
purview but using the imprimatur of
science in order to push it
and this leads in reverse to what i call
the bleed over effect which is where
people will say things that are
unscientific and then pretend
that the actual science supports them
and so you have this
this people who will say things that are
just political but then they will say
that
this is the science right so that's what
fauci was doing is he was saying
you know not he was saying here is a
political perspective
on what the what the rates of herd
immunity are
but politics is defining that but i'm
now going to say that that's science
and that opens the door to all sorts of
bad things being treated as science
even though they're not actually
scientific and so it's it's a really
high level form of gaslighting
specifically because we all do
science is like the last institution
that we actually respect because it's
verifiable
so if you remove the verifiability of
science and instead you make it into an
institution you guaranteed yourself an
enormous amount of power but only by
undermining
what science was supposed to be in the
first place well they love science
except if you ask them how many genders
there are
exactly and then it gets a little bit
confusing or whether a baby in the womb
is a baby like a minute before it's born
right exactly even though as you know
we're in the middle of surrogacy right
now and basically
a day after or two days after they put
the egg in the sperm together
we know the sex and it's like the
doctors you don't you don't
you know they're rejecting the child how
dare you
it's not a click down menu with you know
47 options uh
this isn't specifically what's in the
book but when i was reading this chapter
on science i was thinking that it's a
little bit sort of like your last book
which that this we're worshiping science
now perhaps instead of worshiping god or
having some
set of beliefs outside of ourselves does
that just seem like the obvious
conclusion of a
of a purely secular society yeah we'll
just worship things that will change
every day
yeah i mean i think that's right i think
that human beings have a religious
impulse and somebody's something's gonna
fill that religious impulse and why not
the thing that has brought us
unbelievable prosperity high levels of
technological advancement
it's prevented up to this point disease
and death in extraordinary numbers
right why wouldn't you worship that
thing the problem is it's not a thing
it's a process
so you can certainly have respect for
the process but there have to be some
guiding values beyond just the process
the problem is that people don't have a
habit of following the
the system they're more interested in
just appointing people as their great
leaders
chapter six the radicalization of
entertainment this is where you tell me
to cancel netflix right
you know i i don't say that everybody
should cancel netflix or disney plus i
just say that you should go and
subscribe to daily wire when we bring
out new
entertainment content because listen i i
understand i watch
all these same tv shows but the the
point about the radicalization of
entertainment
is just the the attempt the the pretty
clear attempt now
to get rid of full storylines the the
open attempt
to throw people out of hollywood it used
to be at least they would try to cover
it up
the open attempt now to throw people out
of hollywood for not going along with
the program
the the amazing statement that the
academy awards is now going to be
predetermined based on
what color the leads in your film are or
what your staffing levels are of a
particular sexual orientation
it's absolutely insane and and that does
have a rather
marked impact on how people think about
the world because obviously
entertainment is very emotionally driven
people tend to think about politics on
the back of their emotional state
and so if the entire entertainment
apparatus is taken over
by the left and it is not in fact
appealing to the market it is more
acknowledging that because it has a
monopoly in the market it doesn't have
to appeal to the market whatever
they sell you will buy if they know that
they're just going to continue doing
this
do you think that we can build better
things and eventually get to the place
where netflix won't be necessary and
disney plus won't be necessary and
everything else i mean they have a lot
of legacy product
i mean the reason that i subscribe to
disney plus is not because i want to see
any of the new stuff it's because i want
my kids to be able to see the old stuff
and you just skip that little warning at
the front telling them that they're
racist for watching lady and the [ __ ]
um but uh yeah i i it'll take time i
mean hollywood was a 100-year enterprise
so
this is the bottom line of all this this
stuff takes time conservatives are
always looking for like a turnkey
solution
because that's always what we do in
business but most of this stuff is stuff
that
members of the left have spent decades
building right and the irony is it's
like
man we need new stories we've discussed
this a million times but star wars is
basically dead they killed it now the
marvel movies are basically dead they
killed them now it's like
we just need new stories if nothing else
and then we got to figure out
the way to get them out there and the
way to put them together but we but it's
actually it starts with the story
it does and it also starts with people
who are willing to actually put money
into these things
and that's a risky endeavor i mean
hollywood's risky and when business
people
on the right think about business they
don't think about hollywood because
hollywood is is
such a risk i mean the last person who
actually invested in a movie and made
money from it
in hollywood doesn't exist right no
hollywood accounting has its own
term right i mean so it's going to take
people who are really committed to the
cause to actually start making
entertainment
uh that appeals to a broader spectrum of
people and by the way that's exactly
what you guys are doing right
we're doing it yeah i mean that's
definitely what we're focused on at the
moment for sure
yeah all right we talked about chapter
seven but anything you want to add on
the fake news i mean is there anyone
like do you turn on anyone at this point
i thought jake tapper was sort of the
last hope at cnn to me he's gone in all
the way like is there anyone
in mainstream media at this point that
you're like ah you're not completely
horrible
which is all i would ask they can be
mostly horrible but just not completely
horrible yeah i mean
the way that i tend to characterize this
is there they're no longer journalists i
watch
there are acts of journalism that i will
watch what i mean by that is that i i
don't actually believe in the idea that
journalists are sort of a separate class
of higher human being
because i don't think they very often
follow the processes of journalism they
themselves espouse
uh and so i'm mostly looking for people
who commit acts of journalism and that's
really what twitter is for right
jake asks a good question you're like
okay well that was a good question it's
not like i all of a sudden you know buy
hook light and sync or everything that
jake tapper tells me
but when somebody commits an active
journalism then they deserve praise and
when they
commit an act of journalism and then
they certainly do not
uh chapter eight this seems like the
right way to end this before we get to
the conclusion
unfriending americans we shouldn't hate
everybody ben was that what your tweet
from earlier today was all about yeah i
mean it was pretty easy it was amazing i
was talking to some people on the left
about polarization
uh maybe a few weeks ago and people were
throwing around
ideas many of which i thought were silly
like get rid of gerrymandering i'm like
well we've had gerrymandering since the
beginning and i'm pretty sure that our
polarization is not because of
gerrymandering
um i and i said i have a very simple
thing that all of us could do today
go online today on twitter find somebody
who voted for somebody
that you didn't vote for right whether
say trump and then say that person's a
human being
that's all that's that's the whole thing
that's the whole tweet and uh
nobody took me up on it very few people
on the left i saw were taking me up on
this today i was seeing a lot of people
on the right
who are tweeting out here are a bunch of
people on the left who i am interested
in reading and respect and disagree with
but i find them an interesting person
i'm i've yet to see anybody from the
left tweet in fact the only thing i saw
was somebody from media matters tweeting
out my bad old tweets right
to demonstrate that i am not worthy of
being treated that way because
that sort of radical asymmetry where
people on the right
tend to consider people on the left
mistaken but people on the left tend to
consider people on the right evil
uh that radical asymmetry is not going
to be cured anytime soon
at what point does that uh radical
asymmetry no longer work like when these
people
lie over and over so when they lie about
kavanaugh and they lie about crt and
they lie about election bills and we
know they're lying and they know we're
lying and
they know we know they're lying they
continue to lie the whole thing at what
point
is it honest is it just evil like really
and i don't want to get you know me i
don't want to get to that hyper-partisan
place but at what point do we just have
to call it for what it is
not to say there can't be a couple of
good people who have different political
beliefs but that the machinery of it is
just
endless lying well i mean i think that
as i say in the book the institutions
themselves have become these sorts of
machines
in many cases and so there are only two
choices you can try to fix the machinery
from within
or you can just pose alternatives to the
machinery that out-compete them and
destroy them
uh and when it comes to the media i'm
fully convinced there is no fixing the
new york times there's no fixing cnn
there's no fixing you know the the
washington post
you need to compete from outside and you
need to take them down and and i i think
that that is a worthwhile endeavor
shapiro we both have one minute
remaining 60 seconds i want fastest ben
shapiro white pill stuff right now like
how do people feel good about all this
that's
that's the direction i'm trying to go
with this show and i know that's what
you're trying to do
i mean i think the reason that you can
feel good is because we have not started
to push back yet
and i think a lot of people on the right
thought oh trump was the pushback no
trump was you might you voted
now you have to actually push back in
the places it matters in your own life
you have to push back on the school
board you have to push back your
corporation and believe you me
more people agree with you then disagree
with you at these places because you're
not even taking radical points of view
when you say i don't want
my business telling me how to think
about how i'm a racist i don't want
my kid taught that stuff in school i
don't think that i as a religious person
ought to be forced into participating
into act in activities i don't like most
americans agree with you which means
that there is fertile ground here
the left has pushed so far i think
they've pushed too far and i think the
blowback is only beginning
shapiro you still got it i appreciate it
i think
i think if you stick with it you're
going to make something of yourself good
seeing you brother good to talk to you
be well
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell